what exactly they've done i saw the
furloughs being
okay brilliant thank you everyone thanks
very much for joining us today it's uh
just after 4
30 on the 17th of december 2020
um this is the meeting of the northeast
irish district council's cabinet
um we'll get straight on with the agenda
uh
first item is apologies for absence do
we have any
um nikki uh none of being received chair
okay lovely thank you um and then any
any declarations of interest which any
members wish to declare
no procedure okay thank you and then
minute of the last meeting held on the
12th
of november have you all had a chance to
have a look at those
and i'll be happy to confirm them as a
true and accurate record
i can see indicating so we'll we'll
accept those then thank you
and then the next item is a is a paper
for me which is a
uh review of the council plan so we did
receive this
or a very similar report at full council
back in november which obviously as an
attachment the uh
the presentation which karen gave
highlighting some of the key
achievements which
um obviously we can uh we can go through
very quickly but things like
freezing council tax the introduction of
the older
all older people strategy um lots of
work around the
uh the bsl charter and
supporting children in care and care
leavers a heck of a lot of work around
climate change
and and the work that's gone into the
strategy there and
the actions that we've been taking there
um as well as
um improving services through the
transformation program
um and uh supporting parish and town
councils
lots of work we've written all as well
as we know so there is quite a lot of
really good
positive improvements that we're making
there despite the impact that we've had
through covid we know that kobe has
impacted on delivery of certain
aspirations within the council plan and
as a result of that and as a result of a
few other issues
there is a request within this report to
to amend some of the key performance
indicators
in relation to some of the council plan
uh aims and ambitions so that's what
we're being asked to do we're being
asked to note the achievements made in
the council plan
as in the appendix dependent one and
also to approve
changes to the performance framework as
outlined in appendix
ii um i'm happy to move that is there a
second
a second sure thank you thank you
council parking and any of the comments
any cabinet members wish to remark on
any of the achievements in their areas
now oh carolyn would you like to come in
cancer yeah
yeah just um huge thanks to wilson to
all departments and for all the costs
working i know that
they have some benefits have helped us
enormously in economic growth
uh we had a new director start in the
middle of all this and stuff changes and
i think it's been a tremendous effort
and
we've you know it would be unfair to let
this opportunity pass without saying
there's
other lots of other targets that have
been achieved that weren't even
actually official targets in terms of
numbers of businesses supported so
huge thanks to everybody i absolutely
agree
and one of the key ones uh that wasn't
in in the council plan originally
because who could have foreseen it was
covered itself and our community
response to covered which has
been absolutely tremendous and
absolutely echo uh the thanks there to
all the officers for
all of the incredible work over the
course of this year um which really has
been incredible
so thank you for that council relic uh
councillor kenyon
yeah just to add on the the climate
change work
i think compared to two years ago we're
in a a hugely
better position as a council now it's
got a lot more focus
throughout the whole council and the
work that we're doing
um is starting to we're taking a lead in
the county
as well on the climate change issues and
i think that's a reflection of a lot of
hard work by the offices
and uh political choices that the
council have made
council have made to pursue that uh
crucial long-term issue throughout for
all our residents so
um yes that's really really good
progress that we're making on that now
absolutely thank you very much ken for
kenya for that okay
any other comments from anyone if not
i'll
uh it's been moved and seconded so i'll
move to the vote all those in favor
brilliant that's carried thank you very
much and then we move to the
second report which is a an update on
uh performance from uh july to september
so quarter two uh of the current year
um caf do you want to just give us a
brief summary of
um of where we are with performance at
the moment and highlight any
any specifically any areas where we're
uh where we're
that are sort of flagged yeah
yeah that's absolutely fine so obviously
members are aware that with this a huge
amount of targets in the
uh the council performance framework so
on the summary side overall
there's 105 targets of which
42 are on track so that's 40 percent
uh 25 of those have been 25 targets have
been affected by covid
and they're detailed in the appendix so
you've got some information around those
but essentially the coded ones are ones
such as
um where it's delays to delivery of
projects or protocols or strategies so
there's no reason that those
document documentation won't be
completed but they're going to be
completed a little bit later than
envisaged because we've had to divert
resources to frontline services rather
than
developing strategies but as cabinet
members will be aware
teams are obviously trying to do both to
try to develop
things for the future but also react to
operational needs at the same time
and also some events have had to be
postponed because of obviously covered
restrictions
and the other sorts of areas of where we
have chosen to divert resources so for
instance
when initiatives like litter pics and
school patrols things like that
we've had to divert to other business
needs at this point in time but once
again these things will be going back
onto the scene
as resources allow and then obviously
the the obvious one is
leisure facilities and obviously that's
been affected by the
uh the closures of the size at various
times so obviously the numbers are lower
than
than the original targets for footfall
but once again this is a temporary
situation and we expect those
numbers to pick up uh throughout the
rest of the council plan period so
they're really the things that have been
affected by covid
um we've already achieved nine of the
targets in the framework
and then the only one we flagged this
time is on alert
is the one environment
of five which is deliver for proactive
planning enforcement exercises per year
we popped it on alert this time because
it's not likely that
we will achieve that for this year
and you can see from the report that
that's essentially
whilst planning obviously trying to
address enforcement issues as they arise
delivering proactive reinforcement at
this time is proving difficult because
of enforcement capacity and recruitment
issues
so that's why we find it as alert we're
not expecting four proactive exercises
to be undertaken this year
and that's the only one we have put on
alert the others are either on track or
been affected by kirby for the sorts of
issues that have outlined
obviously this report's got the ones
under review as well
so it'd be good to see a q3 this will be
a much ideal report and it should be
clearer as well so that
will make it easier for members and the
public to give you the council's overall
performance
brilliant thanks very much kath i think
yeah you're absolutely right on the
uh enforcement issue obviously that's
only relatively recently
we've taken the paper to increase
capacity
uh in that area of the council so
hopefully that albeit
won't be achieved this year it hopefully
will um start to
to pick up and improve um in the
forthcoming year
okay thank you for that uh any other
questions or comments for
uh charlotte trump's doing
uh yeah thank you chair i just wanted to
expand uh
shortly for anybody watching on that
planning enforcement
um target i think as you say absolutely
right we've
recently approved his cabinet the
planning enforcement
protocol and also the service review
we've now got
um additional temporary resources in
place
which are clear in uh some of the
long-running cases and
making really good progress actually
i've been discussing with the head of
planning
and with karen um and then obviously
going forward we're hoping to recruit
permanently
early in the new year um so hopefully we
should be making a lot more progress but
we are
we are making a lot of progress at the
moment anyway so just wanted to expand
on that for people
um quick question for kath are there any
other targets which are particularly
sticky or frustrating and
aren't moving on um as they should be
obviously we would discuss
enforcement there but that's that's sort
of been covered are there any other
uh targets that we ought to just be
aware of
i don't think at this point in time i
mean obviously the covered thing's not
going away is it so
those that have been affected by covid
it's it's hard to know what will happen
with those going forward but i think
um outside of the kobe's ones
no there's nothing that in the report
that
it's been raised with me to raise uh
more than that than i have done so to be
honest
uh i think it'd be good to get the q31
when it's a lot tiny reporting more
manageable in the numbers
and then i think it'll be easy to to see
that but no
nothing springs to mind to be honest so
no concerns to report
okay thanks we've been asked to help the
reports i'm i'm happy to
to move that we do so do you have a
second
yeah thank you council rennick all those
in favor
thank you that's carried and the next
report then
is uh over to you councillor powell
uh for the report on uh delegated powers
under understated behavior
crime and policing act yeah the purpose
of this report
is to review and confirm uh the
designation of richard holmes
as the appropriate person or authority
to
issue community protection notices
under section 43 of the anti-social
behavior order
as we know anti-social behavior is a
problem that we take very seriously
and this report in many ways clears up
one or two
things that um that uh that need to be
brought up to date
um it clarifies uh some of the issues
um that need to be uh
dealt with um and we also
seek in this report to make sure that
richard are also the
appropriate tenancy related enforcement
uh action um so unless there any
questions chair i would move the
recommendations in 6.1
thanks council pal the only quick
question from me
i don't know if whether karen or jill
could answer this whether
um this doesn't this only designates
written
homes to be able to issue cpns but we as
a council is still able to issue them
presumably as well
our environmental health service i can
see karen nodding so i'm assuming that's
okay
yes we issue them through our community
safety team um and our legal department
so yes
we'll issue community protection notices
and community protection warnings yeah
so this is just about giving whitnall
the the ability to protect as well
yeah the delegation yes yeah okay that's
great uh uh
council renee you have a question yeah
same question as you originally about
um about who can who actually um
has got the cpa so how many people are
together between the two organizations
and what's the qualification for this
what what is how do you
an individual person's how is that
monitored in terms of competency
and there's there's no qualification uh
it goes through our legal team so it's a
legal process it's a local government
power which we have similar to issuing a
fixed penalty notice etc so we have the
power to issue a community protection
notice
i know that lisa's um on the call if she
wants to add anything but
um we have authorizations and
delegations from
from the council's constitution and it
comes down through that so we have
delegated powers
on behalf of the council to issue
community protection notices
we have to have an evidence so we have
to have the evidence base and we have to
be a
uh confident that we can win a case or a
disputing court
um but yes we we use our legal team and
our
authorised officers to issue them thanks
is there anything you want to add to
that lisa thank you council adele
um just to say that all the community
protection notices because they are um
they can be appealed they do come
through to legal so
um any any across either the council or
richmond homes
they come through to the legal team
we've already got templates usually come
through to myself so we've got a bit of
consistency
um as to to what's contained within them
um
i was going to make another point um
with regards to richard holmes i think
um council ren where you'd asked how
many people are authorized to
to deal with them certainly for written
word homes what i'm hoping that they'll
do and i'm going to encourage them to do
is actually
um delegate to to specific officers that
have received training from legal
services
and it is only a handful this is not
going to be a free-for-all where where
uh
officers can do as they like and so
there will still be some controls in
place
and some and we can review that anyway
does that answer the question that's
exactly where i was going just wanted to
see if there was a consistency there and
it was being
somebody was overseeing it in terms of
who was issuing these but
that's answered perfectly thank you and
it's so important because we are seeing
a slight increase in challenges
um not just to the community protection
notices but also to the warnings which
is the pre
pre-kind of legal stage so it's so
important that we do get it right
absolutely thanks thank you uh council
parking you had a question
yeah just uh just a quick one is it is
it possible it's probably for uh
for councillor powell i don't know but
is it possible to uh to get some
reporting on this
uh from an old uh built it baked into
the
into the management agreement perhaps
i think it should be monitored it's an
important part of uh
of what we're doing as a delegated power
hopefully over to you again well just
thank you guys i think that's a good
point to make
uh it's something that i will discuss
with the monitoring officer okay
thank you uh any other comments or
questions on this paper
um if not i think council power you move
the recommendations i'm happy
to second and uh all those in favor
okay that's carried thank you very much
uh and then
we can get back to my agenda from the
ipod
uh we moved to private session
so can i thank members of the public for
uh for
uh attending and and observing the
cabinet meeting today
uh and wish you all a a very merry
christmas and happy new year
and on that note i'll move that the
public be excluded from the meeting
during the discussion of the following
items of business to avoid the
disclosure to them
exempt information as defined in part
one of schedule 12
a to the local government act 1972
thank you if we can move to
not live
you